but what we wanted to really do
throughout the book was see where
quarantine was being experimented with
or the technical limits of isolation
were being pushed today where would such
a person go this is down in a salt mine
known as the waste isolation pilot plant
it's outside carlsbad new mexico it's
near the border with texas
so to be clear it's not a quarantine
facility for nuclear waste which i'll
get to in a second it's an isolation
facility and on top of that it's a pilot
plant so it's a it's an experimental
facility but so this is where nuclear
waste is being buried by the u.s
government it's not the kind of nuclear
waste that you might picture but it's
nuclear waste in the sense of fabrics
and gowns and gloves and scientific
equipment like microscopes desks pens
papers that were used by scientists in
laboratories where they were developing
the nation's nuclear arsenal
and so those materials that may may or
may not be contaminated but also do pose
a risk to the biosphere are being
shipped to new mexico they're being put
into giant caskets and then they're
being lowered into the depths of the
earth 2150 feet into these huge salt
deposits the room itself is very roughly
the size of a tennis court and then
there's 56 of those rooms throughout
these panels so when you go down into
the depths and drive around through the
salt
you know you can often enter into
hallways where it's difficult even
necessarily to see the very end of it
but so there are several interesting
things here one is that the salt is
actually a kind of a plastic mineral
what i mean by that is that when you
apply enough pressure to it salt moves
almost like a marshmallow or was
described to us as molasses in january
and so when you look closely and you can
see it a little bit in this photograph
the salt is actually crushing its way
back into these corridors and rooms but
that's by design so salt is not only
resistant to radiation and can block it
so it's already a shield against these
the radioisotopes that are being emitted
from the uh from the waste or or should
there be an accident
but also the whole point is that once
humans abandon this architectural
structure and no longer go down into it
the salt will just continue to crush
it'll squeeze in and basically form a
kind of crystalline tomb for all of the
things that are buried within it there's
a a project
that really caught our attention because
it was something that we found
throughout the history of quarantine
which was how do you communicate risk to
individuals and to people and how do
they believe what you're saying so if
you're trying to convince people
thousands of generations from now and
you're dealing with nuclear waste that's
going to be dangerous for at least 10
000 and possibly many millions of years
how do you convince them that this is in
fact a dangerous substance that they
should not in fact dig it up and that
it's something to be avoided you know we
saw even during covet 19 that people
didn't believe that covid and still
don't believe that it's a real disease
that think that the vaccine is actually
a bio weapon you know there are people
that don't if you don't trust the
information that's coming to you why on
earth would you trust some sign that you
found that was written 8 000 years ago
and it's in the middle of the desert
telling you not to dig
so that may sound like a very niche
thing to be concerned about but in fact
there's a lot of real worry that that
whip is going to be disinterred
and so beginning in the 1980s there was
a series of department of energy funded
roundtables that looked at bringing
together semioticians anthropologists
linguists experts in religion
even experts in radiation sickness and
brought them all together to kind of
brainstorm what we could do to prepare
future generations to believe the
message of of danger some is kind of
titanic land art there's one that's a
giant landscape of thorns
where made of concrete the idea
apparently being that you know
aggressive geometric shapes would be
just so terrifying that people will
leave and they won't they would never
consider digging there another one one
of my personal favorites was a it was a
i guess the department of energy in the
1980s was so uh
sensitive to the site of edvard monk's
famous painting the scream but that was
considered so terrifying in the 1980s
apparently that edvard amongst the
screen was going to be reproduced at
various scales throughout the website in
order to scare future generations from
digging there
another one was the raycat proposal
which was actually to make cats
genetically modify domestic house cats
so that if cats came into the region and
there was there was loose radiation and
then radionuclides in the environment
the cats would change color and
potentially even emit fluorescent light
and somehow people with these cats would
conclude from that that there must be a
leaking underground radio a radiation
source and they'll leave the greater
carlsbad area and and go to where their
cats no longer glow the whole point of
whip is that we can take something a
glove that may or may not have traces of
plutonium on it we can take that from a
site somewhere else in the united states
bring it all the way to new mexico and
bury it ostensibly for eternity but so
to do all of that with billions of
dollars in spence it was a 100 000 page
environmental application in order to
get whip constructed it was thus like
the lowly fox that brings down
alexander's gates it was eye-opening and
sobering to realize that in or to hear
rather that in 2014 kitty litter almost
undid the entire thing so there was an
explosion and a barrel uh erupted down
in the depths of whip and released
radiation throughout its own little
panel it's so much so that it caused 500
million dollars worth of damage
parts of whip can no longer be used for
their function which ironically is to
bury nuclear waste but it's considered
too dangerous to go into them and
they've been sealed off
and radionuclides actually were vented
beyond the site but the guy who figured
out what happened realized that someone
had packed
these barrels using the wrong kind of
kitty litter they'd used organic kitty
litter which is based as a wheat based
absorbent it sounds really good it's
organic
but normally it would be a clay-based
absorbent which can help with the
radionuclides and so there was a
chemical reaction between the wheat and
the radiation that caused the explosion
the same person who figured that out
realized that 700 barrels were packed
with the same kitty litter and so far
only one of them has exploded i visited
a lot of nuclear waste sites
like yucca mountain and and ankalo and
europe and and you know scientists are
always charged with making a hundred
percent safe facility and then someone
asked them the question how can you be
sure in a hundred thousand years that
this is safe and they just like well we
can't it's a it's a it's a very
interesting problem and
just briefly along those lines um what's
interesting too is that
many of the people that were actually
tasked to write about
the waste isolation pilot plant and look
at the risk of what's called advertent
entry so that's people that are
deliberately trying to get into whip um
they're basically just saying there is
no way to
stop this you know it's not a burglary
proof vault if you're going to drill
into whip you can do it
and so there's basically no way to
you know to make people not do that but
there was a really interesting quote
from an individual um who we put in the
book um i can't remember it verbatim but
the paraphrase is basically if you look
at the the history of uh uh
human uh facilities that have you know
been buried or put in the center of a
pyramid or a tomb uh that has been of
interest to archaeologists um when you
look at how humans deal with things that
have been hidden away or buried um you
know basically none of our nuclear waste
facilities have any chance of becoming
you know of actually fulfilling their
long-term promise and for somebody in
the nuclear waste industry to say that
it's a bit like okay so you know
you mentioned that whole project of how
to market and you know a lot of the
results of that if you look at the
markings that were on the outside of
king tut's tomb they you know they said
you know your family will become sick
for generations like it's basically all
the same things we mark a nuclear waste
site but it's nothing you know it
nothing makes you want to think there's
gold on the other side of that door more
than that they didn't have glowing cats